for a guy who said that Hillary Clinton
couldn't be trusted with sensitive
secret and classified information Donald
Trump is being really careless with
classified information and at a recent
fundraiser Trump bragged to donors in
the room about a classified battle that
took place in Syria and this was again I
want to restate that that word this was
a classified event the White House has
avoided talking about it it involves US
and Russian connected troops or
mercenaries in Syria last week Donald
Trump held the dinner fundraiser in
Manhattan it was fifty thousand dollars
per person and Trump said that he was
just so impressed by the performance of
the f-18 fighters it was just amazing
that they did ten minutes of strikes and
took out 100 to 300 Russians which now
we sort of have gotten a little more
information they may be Russian Syrian
connected mercenaries it's unclear
exactly what everybody's background is
but none of this had been previously
reported it's all classified and all of
a sudden the transparency trolls come
out of the woodwork and they say hey
this is good we want to know what our
government is doing and I agree with
them but by Trump's own standards one of
the primary disqualifiers for being
president is being careless with
classified information Hillary Clinton
supposedly was not a good candidate for
president because she was careless with
classified information that's exactly
what Donald Trump is doing here and the
the sort of height of the comedy of
errors that this is White House deputy
press secretary Raj Shah was asked hey
Trump spilled classified information at
this fundraiser Raj Shah said I can't
talk about that because the contents of
it are classified right how brilliant is
that it is sitcom level stupid we might
call it Roseanne level stupid isn't
anybody who voted for Trump scared that
the guy with the nuclear codes is
spilling classified information to
Russians in the Oval Office to a roomful
of donors I would guess that he's
spilling classified information to Sean
Hannity during their nightly phone calls
during which Sean Hannity puts Trump to
bed and actually got an email from a
viewer saying David you know in a way we
should be glad that Trump is this
dominant calm
because sometimes having a little bit of
a clue is dangerous and if Trump had a
little bit more knowledge he might
already have gotten us into something
like george w bush's Iraq war sort of
the idea that total incompetence is
better than slight incompetence with a
clue and some really really bad ideas
and george w bush came off as really
dumb but he had some ideas horrible
hawkish neoconservative ideas and he
acted on them Trump likes to act super
smart but he truly knows nothing and it
might it just might keep him from doing
even more horrible things so I I don't I
don't know what what else to say about
the specifics of this incident
Trump's talking about the deaths of 100
to 300 Russians were not at war with
Russia it's possible that these are
mercenaries of Russian nationality who
are just in Syria on their own but even
like the subject matter here Pat is
incredibly disturbing massive military
power killing one to three hundred
people in Syria well the bottom line is
that the president can declassify
whatever he wants right that's what the
Trump is used as an excuse when he
spilled secrets to the Russians in the
Oval Office sure but you'd like to think
that it would be done for some greater
purpose right like the president has the
American people's best interests at
heart no Trump is just doing it for a
punchline or to brag I mean there's no
greater purpose there yeah the people in
the room had already paid the fifty
grand right so did they really need to
hear about the classified thing that the
United States did and actually the the
one thing I will say is I'm not a
hypocrite on the source of the leak
versus the content of the leak Trump was
completely irresponsible in what he said
now that he said it we should look into
what happened there because 100 to 300
Russian serious mercenaries dying with
supposedly one American ending up
wounded in what is a huge military
offensive given what we thought was
going on in Syria it's actually really
disturbing in terms of what it is that
Donald Trump is doing and what took
place there so now that the cat is out
of the bag we should look into it
immediately